Right now, Republicans are inching closer
to winning
what will be a narrow
majority in the House,
but a majority nonetheless.
Let's bring in CNN anchor John Berman.
He's at the magic wall John.
You know, a lot of these close races
have been tipping red
in the last couple of days.
So where do we see this stand?
And are we going to see a power shift
as soon as today?
The Republicans have it within sight
at this point, Jim.
They control 215 seats.
We've called 215 races for them.
204 for the Democrats.
The Republicans only need
three more seats to control
the House of Representatives.
That will give them to 18.
The Democrats would need to win 14.
And at this point
there are only 16 uncalled races.
You can see Republicans lead in six.
They only need three Democrats
lead and ten, but they need to win 14.
It is pretty easy to see on this map
where Republicans could pick up
those three seats that they need.
I'll just write three up here
to remind us
of what we're looking at in California,
where a lot of these seats are.
By the way,
you think the blue state of California
the Republicans
could, in fact,
crossed that threshold
with just California races?
You have California's
third congressional district.
This is actually a Republican
leaning district.
R plus one.
And the Republican
there is ahead by 9000 votes.
If you go down to the southern part
of the state,
California's 41st
congressional district,
longtime incumbent Ken Calvert
he served for decades in the House
of Representatives.
He holds a 5000 vote
lead with 64% at this point.
This two is a Republican
leaning district.
So just win those two Republican
leaning districts
and they're right on the cusp, Jim.
And then there are also seats alone.
And right now
you have, for instance, California's 45th
congressional district
you have incumbent Michelle Steele,
who is leading ten.
This is a Democratic
leaning district four.
The turnout tends to favor Republicans.
She's ahead by 13,000 votes.
These three races
would give the Republicans control.
And then you pull out
and we go to Colorado.
This race has received
a lot of attention.
This is Lauren Boebert,
California's third.
She's ahead by 1100 votes. 99%.
And all that's left here
is the overseas
military and absentee ballots.
Could that be enough for the Democrats
to take the lead?
Maybe.
But most Democrats and Republicans
you talk to around the country doubt it.
So right there,
that would give Republicans
four of the seats
that they need and control
of the House of Representatives, Jim.
And, you know, it's interesting.
I mentioned Blue California and the fact
that California could be the state
to put Republicans over the top.
If you look two years ago,
these districts are drawn
45 of them were Biden
districts, seven were Trump districts.
Now, you could have 41 in Democratic
hands. 11 in Republican hands.
That's a net minus of four seats there.
That might be the difference
in control for the Democrats, Jim.